it's bringing Tommy Curran he's the
Patriots insider NBC sports Boston do
you have an opinion on that mr. Kraft
saying that Tom Brady is the greatest
player of all time oh no I thought I
thought your summation was outstanding
you can argue both sides you can look at
what Jerry Rice did in there ruthian the
numbers are ruthian in terms of
touchdowns catches
single season career whatever you want
but then if you want to talk
historically and compiling Brady has
more than two seasons on his way to two
and a half seasons worth of postseason
games so does that set him apart I mean
he's 38 games in it's insane
so I don't have necessarily a
quote-unquote hard take but I've always
felt that Jerry Rice was the greatest
player ever but I certainly think the
brady is the greatest quarterback
because he can measure it this underdog
message it feels like that the team has
embraced it now do you think Kansas
City's buying into this that you know
New England's coming in a thunder
underdog technically they are three
point underdogs but do you think Kansas
City is buying into this as well that
you know these aren't the artist
formerly known as the Patriots no recent
stuff what they did last week to San
Diego was embarrassing for San Diego and
made everybody sit up straight and say
well they're different now which they
did suck during the year I don't
understand why the media especially
locally we chewed them up we choose them
up all year they suck on the run defense
they did a bad job roster building
Brady's falling away from throws
Gronkowski's hurt in the shell of
himself so when Brady says everybody
thinks we suck is a catch-all phrase it
was oil nobody actually said suck
we killed them all year long I don't
blame them at all but I think the Kansas
City looks at them and says my god look
at what they just did to this team to
beat us at home we're screwed
not screwed but yeah but I okay so
Brady's talking more to the local media
I don't know if the national media
looked at the Patriots and now
I just said they're more vulnerable this
year than they ever have been
but with Brady and Belichick I would
never bet against them so I don't know
if this is more of a local narrative
than it is a national one that we look
at them as somehow big underdogs well
you're close enough to here and you've
done this long enough where you know
that our market is a strange one and the
success eventually had an expiration
date up here to the point where the
Boston Red Sox were wire-to-wire winners
practically or maybe did set a record
for most regular season wins I can't
remember and every single step they took
was yeah well let's see how they do when
they get into the postseason well
they're not gonna beat the Yankees well
they're not gonna beat the Astros
so it's this drumbeat of negativity that
just continues to churn because that's
you know you can't have a parade every
day after every win well we've almost
pinned the needle so far in the other
direction where I mean Sony Michele was
said to suck up until around week 10 and
they still stand on that you know some
local radio and and you know prominent
folks here a lot of them what do you
think happens this weekend in Kansas
City I think the Patriots are gonna wind
in I think that America is gonna just
again say oh why why why why why Patrick
mahomes is so much fun we could have had
Tyree kill why why Andy Reid poor Andy
Reid but they're gonna get another dose
of Belichick and Brady and I think the
reason for that is health has nothing to
do with anything but they feel better
and that's why the drop off I think in
2018 to 2000 from 2017 I mean what they
did in the Super Bowl was insane I think
a lot of the reason they lost that game
was a personnel decision with Malcom
Butler yeah so they should have been
back to back Super Bowl winners and then
this year they play under whelming Lee
they didn't overnight get old they got
hurt and you know we always talk about
Belichick he takes away your best weapon
well I wasn't sure who that best weapon
is on Kansas City is it Patrick mahomes
or is it Tyreke Hill and if it's Tyreke
Hill
you take him out of his comfort zone
here because it feels like that's where
the game could be won or lost they
haven't done it in either meeting 2017
Oprah open our 2018 he's got about 266
yards receiving he's got four touchdowns
Denver McCord he's their fastest player
he scored two touchdowns on him where he
just ran away from him
75 yard touchdown so you have to station
somebody way back away from the line of
scrimmage and just try and corral him
but the reason the Patriots lost those
games is their inability to stop those
huge 50-yard Plus plays I think that
most coaches can go into a game and say
let's try not give up a 60-yard bomb and
but defense could say yeah we I think we
can do that against Kansas City they
make that happen regardless of how many
precautions you put in-house Grunk
is there any chance Gronk as a threat as
a receiver yes and again just to go back
to that game and again it was week six
but he took over that game late and we
had three catches but Kansas City
eventually lost track of them and he had
the two catches which set up the
game-winning field goal for four Stephen
Gostkowski yeah he can be a threat and
when you look at how well he blocked
last week that was the role that he had
and he still doesn't get available in
the red zone necessarily I don't know
why he's not as quick as he had been
because he was very quick last year but
I do think that he's had a much better
spot than he has been both mentally and
physically then he has been the entire
year he's Tommy Kearney covers Patriots
NBC Sports Boston joining us Dan Patrick
show if you could know the full true
answer to just one of these which one
would you pick why Malcolm Butler was
benched in the Super Bowl or who
orchestrated the Jimmy Garoppolo trade
Butler Butler completely because I got a
pretty good handle on the Garoppolo
thing you want to know what happened
okay they had a plan
Brady screwed everything up by playing
out of his mind from 2014 to 2017 the
plan was to move on from Brady after
2017 and he played so well that in the
2017 season when Garoppolo contract was
coming up ye Dungey is the agent for
Brady and Garoppolo so he had the
insight into Tom's not going anywhere
so Jimmy when they try and slide to you
a 14 million dollar contract that will
accelerate if you become the starter
you're probably not going to want to
take that you'll do better on the open
market so they could never get to a
point where they could convince them
they could franchise him for 24 million
but how's that going to go over the
Brady who's making 15 million there was
just nothing they could do so while
people say well Robert Kraft told Bill
Belichick to trade him I think it's more
of well we're gonna have to do something
here soon
sure would hate to see Tom go anywhere
and then he comes back in and says trade
him for a - you're dead why's that - so
we had to move on I guess I don't know
okay so what happened with Malcolm
Butler Mike why don't we know what I
wanted to know that why don't we know
why he got benched because I think it
has to do with interpersonal relations
and what I think is fascinating is that
whatever happened that irritated so
badly Bill Belichick and maybe the rest
of the coaching staff that wound up with
him benched that Malcolm Butler was
complicit in keeping his mouth shut
about it look no matter how you slice it
I don't care how ill-prepared Malcolm
Butler may have been during that week or
where his head was
Johnson Badham OSI and the other thing
about there Jordan Richards being on the
field cause the Patriots the football
game about would Malcolm Butler have
saved it I don't know for sure but he's
a much better player so he could have so
why wouldn't
or do anything but say yeah well they
made a decision it was disappointing it
sucks but here I am in Tennessee and why
wouldn't the Patriots say anything but
you know he just didn't fit into any of
our packages I mean here's the one crazy
thing I won't go on too long but instead
of benching him they dressed him and
they played him for one play on a punt
you know no you know indiscriminate pun
during the game so he could say that he
wasn't benched so they gave themselves
plausible deniability is saying that it
was packages we just didn't work out so
in some way it was related to some kind
of discipline above which everybody has
sewn their jaw shut about pretty
incredible really is one of the great
mysteries I and you know everything is
kept inside in house there in New
England you know eventually get out
right yeah you know was that should we
get out and I think that nobody is able
to there's bridges too far that we can't
go across but there are plenty of rumors
speculation etc which I'll be happy to
tell you about no mana thank you if the
Patriots win the Super Bowl who retires
me know I'm at it I'm too young for that
I would say Krunk retires not hashtag
Tommy
no not hashtag Tommy yeah I'll see you
in Atlanta no I it's a great story if he
continues to play absolutely okay yeah
he's the underdog now he went from the
greatest player of all time to an
underdog I you know the the scrappy
gritty Gotti you know late draft pick
nobody gave him a chance look at him
flat circle baby time you know how it is
you know he's the modern-day rudy is
what he is it's gonna be they're gonna
do a movie on on Tommy you wait long
enough everything comes around in I know
I'll see I'll see in a minute let's get
crunk okay no no let's not
I might but Paulie would you google that
what's that mean I'm gonna do
yeah that might not be good are you
going to be in Atlanta if the Patriots
aren't in Atlanta sure I am
football world okay alright I just put
that out there I'll be there no matter
what I didn't know if yours was attached
to hashtag number twelve
okay Tommy I know alright then that's a
Tommy Kern NBC Sports Boston and then
we'll get crunk I'm gonna guess that's
drunk it's an offshoot of Gronk oh we're
gonna get Gronk I said you're gonna get
Krunk it's different Boston Krunk is
something different something else other
places I'm gonna have to when I you know
when I talk to Future later today I'm
gonna ask him about that see what he
thinks
for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show ass
[Music]